[Music]
dr wallach
is going to explain to you tonight not
only about cardiac myopathy
but many other things i pray that you
listen closely and carefully
because what you're going to hear may
save your life or the life of your loved
one
dr wallach in 1991 was nominated for the
nobel prize
he's had many many fabulous things in
his life
there's no way i can tell you how
pleased i am to have him here in kansas
city tonight
and i want to turn the time over now to
dr joel wallick would you all give him a
big hand
how many of you grew up on a farm or
still work a farm or have anything to do
with livestock
well i'll tell you what you're my kind
of people because i grew up on a farm in
west st louis county back in the
50s and we start out with beef calves
and if if you raise livestock the only
way to make money is if you raise a lot
of your own feed for those who don't
have that experience
and so we raised our own corn and we
raised our own soybeans in our own hay
and we had a truck come out from the
mill and this truck would come out from
the mill
and it would grind up the corn and the
soybeans and the hay and then we would
add
sacks of vitamins minerals trace
minerals and we make pellets out of it
and this is what we would feed the
calves
in six months time we'd ship them to
market to be slaughtered we'd save back
some of the best ones for ourselves
we'd knock them in the head and eat them
put it bluntly
and it always fascinated me as a
teenager that we did that for those
calves and in six months ship them off
to be slaughtered or we'd eat them
and we wanted to live to be a hundred
years of age without any
aches and pains and guess what
we didn't take any vitamins or minerals
and that bothered me
so i asked my dad i'd say hey pops how
come
you do that for those calves you don't
do that for us and he'd give me this
good old missouri farm wisdom he'd say
things like
shut up boy you're getting this farm
fresh food and we hope you appreciate it
and of course i was very quiet then
because i didn't want to miss out on any
meals
well then when i went to school i went
to the university of missouri the
school of agriculture and i got my
degree in agriculture
and it was very interesting to me that
i got my major in animal husbandry in
nutrition
my minor was in field crops and soils
then i got into veterinary school
as a freshman veterinary student i
learned to answer to my question
and the answer is this we know how to
prevent and cure diseases in animals
with nutrition
and the reason why we do that is because
we don't have major medical
we don't have hospitalization blue cross
blue shield
we don't have medicare
we don't have hillary to watch out for
us
if you're going to make money as a
farmer you better know how to do stuff
yourself and you better
do it efficiently with feed and
nutrition if you can
well to make a long story short after i
got out of veterinary school i went to
africa for two years and i
was able to fulfill a boyhood dream i
was able to be a frank buck for two
years and work with marlon perkins many
of you will remember him from the mutual
of omaha's wild kingdom
and he's a great gentleman and after two
years of working with elephants and
rhino people used to ask me or
are you a small animal vet or a large
animal vet well i would tell them i'm an
extra large animal vet
because i worked with elephants and
rhinos well after two years he sent me a
telegram and said would you come back to
the saint louis zoo and work with us
we need a wildlife veterinarian at the
zoo for a special project
we were given a seven and a half million
dollar grant from the
um national institutes of health
and what we need is a veterinarian
who'll do autopsies of animals that die
of natural causes in the zoo
i was just overjoyed to do that and so i
came back and and did that
and of course i not only did autopsies
for animals that died in the st louis
zoo but the brookfield zoo in chicago
the bronx zoo new york the national zoo
the la zoo and so forth
and my job again was to do autopsies of
animals that died of natural causes in
the zoo
and looked for a species of animals that
was ultra sensitive to pollution
this is because during the early 60s we
had just learned about pollution and
ecological problems and disasters
and nobody quite knew what to do and so
i was supposed to find a species of
animals that was extra sensitive
to this and use them much like we did
the
canaries in the mine you know the old
welsh coal miners used to put a canary
in a little
wicker cage and take it down in the mine
and if methane gas
or carbon monoxide would leak into the
mine the canary would drop off the perch
and die first
and the men knew to get out before the
mine blew up or they suffocated
well again to make a long story short
over a period of some 12 years
i did 17 500 autopsies and over 454
species of animals
and 3 000 human beings who lived in
close proximity to zoos
and the thing that i found out was this
every animal and every human being who
dies of natural causes
dies of a nutritional deficiency
and that fascinated me went back took me
back to those calves i said gee that's
fascinating everybody is dying of
nutritional deficiencies we could
document this
at autopsy both chemically and
biochemically and so forth and things
you saw
with the eye at the autopsy table well
that fascinated me and i wrote 75
scientific articles
i wrote uh eight multi-author textbooks
and one textbook of my own costs 140
bucks for medical students
and i'm sure the only thing they do is
use them for door stops
and it couldn't get anybody excited i
was on 2020
i was on seventeen hundred newspapers
i was in magazines it was in every new
network tv that you can think of
and guess what couldn't get anybody
excited back in the sixties about
nutrition
so what i did was went back to school
and became a physician
to use everything i had learned in
veterinary school about nutrition in my
human patients
and to no surprise to me it worked spent
12 years up in portland oregon
in general practice and is very
fascinating what i'm going to share with
you tonight is what i learned over those
12 years using nutrition with my human
patients
and if you take home only 10 percent if
you take home only 10
it will save you an enormous amount of
unnecessary misery
it will save you a gob of money and
those of you in missouri know what that
means agav means a lot
and will save you and in fact it will
add on many helpful years to your life
okay it'll add many healthful years to
your life
well you can't do this you can't get
these healthful years you can't
have longevity you can't live to your
genetic potential just falling off a
stump
you have to do some things the first
thing i have to do is convince you
that it is worth doing these things i'm
going to start out by convincing you
that the
genetic potential for human beings is
120 to 140 years our genetic potential
for longevity
okay 120-140 years there's no less than
five
cultures whose people live to be 120-140
starts out in the tibetans in western
china
these people were popularized back in
by james hilton he wrote a book called
the lost horizon
many of you remember reading that as a
pulitzer prize winning book way back
then
and they did a movie of that 1937 it's a
very long movie about three hours you
can get it from any blockbuster video
and i would encourage you to get it and
look at it when you have three hours
it's a great movie
and the oldest living person that has
some documentation i'm sure there's a
certain amount of exaggeration in there
but
there is some documentation was a fellow
a doctor
lee li from china
along this tibetan border and this
fellow
when he was 150 years old quote unquote
received a big certificate
from the imperial chinese government he
was born in 1677
150 years later he was given a
certificate by the imperial chinese
government
for being 150 years and then when he got
to be 200 years they sent him another 50
years later they sent him another
certificate
and supposedly he died at age 256
and as people of that nature he was
written up in the new york times in 1933
when he died
in the london times and so this is
fairly well documented
but he may have only been 200 years old
i don't know if he was 256 but this is
the
person that led james hilton to write
that
story then uh there's in 1967 or 68
there was a remake of that movie it was
a color version if you haven't seen that
was called shangri-la
i'd urge you to see that then in eastern
pakistan
there's a group of people called the
hunzas and these people are very famous
for longevity
120-140 if you've been in alternative
health for any length of time you've
heard their name at least
then in what is now western uh russia it
used to be the soviet union
the russian georgians were made famous
during the 70s by dan and yogurt
you remember the old crimea war veterans
they
get their uniform on they'd hold a saber
up and they would get a cup of dan and
yogurt and smile a lot and you're
supposed to make the mental leap
that it was the dan and yogurt that made
them live to be 120.
then just south of them the armenians
the abkhazians and the azerbaijanis are
famous at least
in in the soviet union they were studied
for some 60 years
because they routinely lived to be 120
to 140.
in fact in 1973 the january issue of the
of the um national geographic 1973
january uh national geographic did a
special article on people who lived to
be a hundred
and are older and they featured these
people
and there's a great pictorial article
you know national geographic
is very good about coming out with
pictures and three of these dozens of
pictures that were in that article
i remember one of them was a lady who
was 136 years old
she was sitting in a wicker chair with a
big cuban cigar in one hand and an
8-ounce glass of vodka in the other
and she was partying she was having a
good time she was not in a nursing home
all slouched over and you know ready to
have somebody take another 2500 bucks
out of her
checking account she was enjoying
herself at 136.
then there was a semi circle of couples
boy girl boy girl boy girl and they were
celebrating their 100th and 115th and
120th
wedding anniversaries then the third
picture
that i remember is a gentleman who is
picking tea leaves up at the timber line
in the caucasus mountains
in armenia and um he was listening to
a one of these little transistor radios
back then
and according to his birth records and
and baptismal records as military
records and the birth records of his
children
the national geographic said that he was
167 years of age and the oldest living
person
at that time on the western hemisphere
the vilcabamba indians
in ecuador are very famous they live in
the andes and then in southeastern peru
my favorites the titicacas
i just like them because i like the name
they're sort of east of the
machu picchu uh the old community
the titty kakas live around lake
titicaca and of course they're very
famous
for living to be 120-140
well in may 11th just about a month ago
the oldest living american at this time
and documented through the guinness
world book of records was margaret skeet
she was from radford
virginia she died at age 115 and
she died of a nutritional deficiency you
can tell that from her her obituary
she died of the complications of a fall
what did she die from
osteoporosis very good she died of a
calcium deficiency she had no heart
disease no cancer
no diabetes no other infirmities but she
died three weeks after a fall because
she didn't have enough calcium
very interesting also her daughter said
that she had a craving for sweets until
she died and that's a
disease called pica we'll talk about
that a little bit
but usually when you have a craving for
chocolate if you're a chocoholic or a
sugar a holic
that means that you have a deficiency of
chromium and vanadium and we'll talk
about that
in a minute then in a third world
country in niger
in africa a chief by the name of bower
at age 126 was eulogized by one of his
wives
so i assume it was plural it had many
wives and she was bragging about him at
his death at age 126
he was still in possession of all his
own teeth
okay so you assume that other faculties
are working too
then here's a gentleman uh from syria at
age 133 he died in july of 1993
and he was in the grandest world book of
records not because he was 133 there's
been many people live longer than that
not because he remarried for the fourth
time at age 80 but because he fathered
nine children after the age of 80
and this meant if you add up nine months
for each child in a year for
breastfeeding for each one and a year
between each one of the children
he was still fathering children after
age of 100 and that's what got him into
the guinness world book of records
so there's still hope for you fellas
then those of you who like science in
november of 1993
those six biospherians came out of that
dome
in arizona they were in there for two
years
three couples and they were supposed to
eat the perfect food and recycle the
atmosphere and grow their own food and
whatnot and have no pollution in their
water
or air or food and when they came out
they're examined by medical
gerontologists from ucla university of
california los angeles
and they put all this information their
physical their blood work and so forth
into the medical computers at ucla
and the medical computer said that and
projected that they could live to be 165
years old if they continued to do
what they were doing so all of that just
says to you that
there's a there's a possibility you can
live to be 120 to 140
and when i grew up on the farm we could
grow 200
bushels of corn per acre and with all
the labor and all the fertilizer and
everything else you did
you could make a profit if you grew 200
bushels per acre but if you only got 100
bushels per acre and put out that same
effort in the same
fertilizer cost you'd lose money and so
i want you to think about it the average
lifespan for an american today is 75.5
average lifespan for an md or a doctor
is 58.
you want to gain 20 years statistically
just don't go to medical school
you want to live to be 120-140 there's
only two basic things it's real simple
two things
remember number one you have to avoid
the pitfalls
you have to not step on the land mines i
call it
and those are in the military you know
what that means um
you do something stupid like step on one
of those things you kill yourself
wastefully or unnecessarily of course if
you play russian roulette
or smoke excessively or drink
excessively or
wear a black sweatsuit and run down the
middle of the highway at two o'clock in
the morning you're going to get struck
by a car
all of those things are foolhardy but
it's amazing how many tens of thousands
of people die in america from doing
those stupid things every year
the last thing i will share with you on
that subject of avoiding the land mines
i'd suggest very strongly to you that
you avoid going to doctors
and i'm going to back up that statement
which is a pretty strong statement with
a
statement from ralph nader's group in
january of 1993
just about a year and a half ago january
13th he put out a news release based on
a three-year study on the causes of
death in american hospitals and it was
fifteen hundred page report
this three-year study and i'm not gonna
waste your time or mine by
going over the whole thing word for word
but the bottom line
says a lot the bottom line says a lot
and here it is quote this is from ralph
nader now he's a consumer advocates
advocate for those of you don't know him
who watches out for us quote
three hundred thousand americans are
killed each year in hospitals alone as a
result of medical negligence
unquote i'm going to read that figure
again because it's a huge figure
quote three hundred thousand americans
are killed each year in hospitals alone
as a result of medical negligence
unquote
he didn't say he slipped away quietly
out of neglect in a corner somewhere
while they're waiting for an x-ray he is
the word killed when you use the word
killed that means there was a procedure
the doctor was doing went wrong somehow
that means that they gave them a wrong
prescription
they put a decimal point in the wrong
spot and gave them an incorrect
dosage these people were killed
three hundred thousand to appreciate how
big a figure that is
you have to compare that with our
military losses in vietnam over
ten years where we lost fifty six
thousand people over ten years or an
average of only five thousand six
hundred a year
on a field of battle where people had
guns and artillery and explosives trying
to kill each other
and millions of people poured out into
the streets and protested that war
we had political anarchy in the last
three years of the war
students took over universities and
colleges with guns and explosives
national guardsmen shot
students at kent state in ohio we chase
the president of the presidency
for five thousand six hundred military
personnel a year
and here's one profession that takes
your tax money
in the form of medicare and medicaid and
kills three hundred thousand of us a
year according to ralph nader and i
believe him he has no axe to grind
and you can go out in the street any day
of the week in any city and there isn't
even a
crazy street preacher out there with a
sign that says protect us from doctors
i want you to think about that folks
that's number one you have to avoid
stepping on the land mine so there's a
certain value in treating yourself when
you can
or preventing disease so you don't have
to get treated
now the second thing you have to do
number two is you have to do the
positive things
you have to do the positive things and
i'm going to
start out here by just putting a figure
up on the board it's the number 90
and you need 90 nutrients in your diet
every day you need 60 minerals
you need 16 vitamins
you need 12 essential amino acids or
protein building blocks
and you need three essential fatty acids
you need
90 nutrients in your daily diet
otherwise you're going to get a
deficiency disease if you don't have
them
in complete numbers and optimal amounts
well i can tell you that i was one of
those nerds back when i was in college i
had a clipboard we didn't have computers
back then so i had a clipboard and i was
one of those funny guys with glasses and
would walk up and down in the student
union there in columbia and say
do you take vitamins and minerals i was
still fascinated by that and
and of course people kind of look at you
crazy and say well yeah i take vitamin e
and i'd wait for them to come up with
the other 89 and they didn't they just
oh i take vitamin e
well today if you ask people do you take
food supplements they say oh yeah i take
tums
because that's what you know they hear
all the time well again you need 90
nutrients if you're going to make it
but the newspaper is no and the
magazines and tv and radio knows
that we're interested in health and
longevity and
and supplements so they all talk to us
not because the medical profession has
asked them to do that in their stead the
medical profession doesn't say hey we're
so busy saving people with surgery and
chemotherapy and radiation
and pharmaceuticals would you please
educate the people on nutrition
they do it because it sells newspapers
my favorite article of all time appeared
in time magazine april 6
1992 and if you haven't read it i'd urge
you to get it out of a school library or
public library and photocopy it
stick one copy on the door in the
bathroom and one on the refrigerator
it's a cover article it says the real
power of vitamins new research shows
they may help fight cancer heart disease
and the ravages of aging
again there are six positive pages in
here there's only one negative sentence
and was issued by a medical doctor who
is asked by the writer of the article
what do you think
what do you think about vitamins and
minerals for people as food supplements
and here's what the doctor said quote
popping vitamins doesn't do you any good
sniffs dr victor herbert
a professor of medicine at new york
city's mount sinai medical school we get
all the vitamins we need in our diets
and taking supplements just gives you
expensive urine
unquote well to give you a missouri
translation of that
that means you're just peeing away your
dollars if you take vitamins and
minerals
you might as well wad up your dollars
and throw them in the toilet and flush
them away because you're not getting any
redeeming value from it those quacks are
just taking your money for those
vitamins and minerals
that's what he was trying to say got
published
so it must be true right i'll tell you
what
after having done those 17 500 autopsies
and 454 species of animals
from around the world and 3 000 humans
and liking to be healthy myself and
having children and
grandchildren and not too distant future
great grandchildren i'd rather pee out
50 cents or a dollar a day worth of
excess vitamins and minerals it's pretty
cheap insurance
because if you don't invest in yourself
to the tune of a buck a day for vitamins
and minerals
guess what you're going to invest in the
lifestyle of md somewhere
because when you pay the medical doctor
your fee for going to see him
not one penny that goes to study how to
diagnose or treat or prevent a
catastrophic disease in a little child
like who was in here earlier
or how to prevent or diagnose or treat
better
breast cancer prostate cancer in adults
guess what that money goes for pays a
doctor's mortgage makes his mercedes
payment
it pays the tuition for his kids to go
to medical school that have it you know
have it is up in bastion
pays a tuition for his kids to go to law
school at yale
i believe because we've made doctors
wealthy
between 1776 and the second world war
the u.s government spent 80 million
dollars on health care and health care
research and studies
right now we're one point two trillion
dollars a year
for health care and it's free
we all know it's free right
i like that lady she says like heck it's
not free but we're supposed to believe
it's free and everybody wants more of it
and more free stuff
well tell you what if we use the human
type medical system
for the agricultural industry and the
livestock your hamburger costs 275
dollars a pound
on the other hand if you use the
agricultural
health system that we use in animals for
humans your monthly insurance premiums
for a family of five would be ten
dollars a month
you take your choice well i believe
since
we've made them wealthy through
insurance programs and government
subsidies
i believe they owe us something i
believe they owe us at least as much as
the
industries do according to for instance
recall notices
this was started of course i don't know
25 years ago when ralph nader
learned that the ford motor company had
made a pinto car with a rear end gas
tank that would blow up
when he got hit from behind at 20 miles
an hour fry everybody in the car
and when people complained to ford motor
company they said well you're just dumb
for getting in a car accident
we're not going to pay you for that
ralph nader says no it's a faulty design
so he went to a federal court and the
judge agreed with him and
through a court order forced ford motor
company to send everybody
a recall notice with a registered letter
bring that car in and they'll fix it for
nothing
but they kill three hundred thousand a
year and nobody protests as long as we
get ours free
and that scares me that attitude at any
rate
i've got a bunch of these recall notices
you should have gotten over the last
couple of years we'll go through them
quickly
number one is ulcers how many of you
ever heard that ulcers is caused by
stress
okay everybody's heard that if you don't
raise your hand you've got alzheimer's
or you're fibbing right
well we knew 50 years ago in in the
veterinary industry that
uh ulcers at least in pigs was caused by
bacteria called helicobacter pylori and
of course we couldn't get one of these
high-priced stomach surgeons from mayo
clinic in fact we always used to yell
hold the mayo
when they say stuff like that and uh
otherwise your pork chops would be 275
a pound to pay for that kind of surgery
and we learned that with a trace mineral
called bismuth and the tetracycline
antibiotic that we could prevent and and
cure
those stomach ulcers and pigs without
surgery so that's what we did cost
five bucks to cure a pig of stomach
ulcers with uh
bismuth the trace mineral and
tetracycline well the national
institutes of health now not the
national enquirer
but the national institutes of health
came out in february of this year
february 1994 and said ulcers are caused
by a bacteria called helicobacter pylori
not stress
and they can be cured they actually use
the cure word in this news release
medical researchers never do that they
always say shows promising results or
may be beneficial
they use the cure word national
institutes of health and they say can be
cured with a combination of the trace
mineral bismuth and tetracycline
well for those of you don't know what
business comes in you can get it from
any grocery store or drugstore it's pink
about 295 for an eight ounce bottle and
it's called pepto
bismol so a teaspoon a day full of
pepto-bismol and some
mice and calf scour pellets you can take
care of ulcers
now you have your choice whether you're
going to treat your own for five bucks
or go get
whittled on that's your choice
then what's the number two cause of
death in americans terrible disease
called cancer right
now doctors get information on cancer
you think they'd photocopy that when
they send you that bill
they should send you some photocopies of
this stuff well in september of 1993
the national cancer institute not the
national enquirer but the national
cancer institute
and the um have at medical school in
boston
did a study on cancer patients and they
came out and they said an anti-cancer
diet was found
well any rate they picked china to do
this study because in one province hinan
province in china
they have the highest rate of cancer in
the whole world
they took 29 000 people for five years
in this study
and what they did was give them
different vitamins and minerals at
double the recommended daily allowance
for americans
now that's a trivial amount for instance
they use vitamin c for one group and
of course the rda recommended daily
ounce for vitamin c is 60 milligrams
double that can be 120 milligrams you
can't go into a health food store and
find a
vitamin c tablet or capsule for less
than 500 milligrams for an adult
of course linus pauling the gentleman
with two nobel prizes says if you want
to prevent and treat cancer with vitamin
c you got to use
10 000 milligrams a day well all the
doctors who used to argue with him
back 35 years ago were all dead and
today linus pauling's still 94 and he
works 14 hours a day seven days a week
on his ranch in the big sur
in california and teaches at the
university of california san francisco
so you have to make up your choice
whether you're going to listen to the
dead doctors or linus pauling
your choice okay vitamin c double the
rda nothing happened vitamin a double
the rda nothing happened zinc riboflavin
the trace mineral molybdenum nice and
nothing happened
in one group they got a major benefit in
this group they got three nutrients at
one time they got
vitamin e they got beta-carotene and the
trace mineral selenium
those three were at double the rda
and if you get a half a percent benefit
in any nutritional or pharmaceutical
experiment
you've made a major improvement in
humanity's
life and so these articles get published
so once you remember that statistic a
half a percent is major benefit
well in this group that received the
vitamin e beta-carotene and selenium for
five years
deaths from all causes were reduced by
nine percent
almost ten out of every hundred or one
out of every ten who were going to die
in that five years from any cause
survived then cancers all cancers
13 percent survived who would have died
without those three nutrients
so 13 out of 100 lived who would have
died and then the type of cancer that
was most prevalent in henon province
stomach and esophageal cancer 21
lived who would have died 21 out of 100
lived
now to me those are significant numbers
and your physician
for the number two cause of death in
america should have sent every one of
you a photocopy that
at least giving the information even if
he didn't want to give you the advice
give you the information let you make up
your own mind
well here's one i think is funny on one
hand and on the other
side it tells you the attitude of
physicians
this has to do with arthritis it was in
september 24th 1993 that it was released
again it was from the habit medical
school in the bastion va hospital
how many of you in here have ever been
to a va hospital anybody in this room
okay good well you know the people
who've been to a va hospital you have
two opportunities to give your life for
your country
once on the field of battle and the
others in the va hospital right
well any rate the title of the release
was chicken protein halts the swelling
and pain of arthritis in a patient trial
and what they did they took people who
failed to respond in any way to medical
treatment for arthritis
these people got gold shots mesotrexate
they got
aspirin prednisone cortisone everything
else you can think of physical therapy
and the only thing left for them was
joint replacement surgery
okay now before harvard medical school
the va hospital was going to give it to
him they said look
we're looking for some people who are
willing to suffer for 90 more days just
three months
because we want to try something a short
term experiment and they got 29
volunteers
what they did for those 29 volunteers
who failed to respond in any way to
medical treatment for arthritis
was they gave them a heaping teaspoon
full of ground up dried chicken
cartilage in their orange juice every
morning
just a heaping teaspoon of ground up
chicken cartilage
and in 10 days according to harvard
medical school all the pain and
inflammation was gone
these are people who didn't respond in
any way to medical treatment
in thirty days they could open up a new
pickle jar that never been opened
and ninety days three months they had
maximum return of function
now here's the funny part the funny part
comes by a statement
of the guy who was the director of that
study from harvard medical school and
here's what he said quote listen to the
words
very important quote after three months
it was clear that the drug was
beneficial
unquote because it worked chicken
cartilage had become a drug
you can see he's thinking about patent
numbers and his eyes are rolling around
with
300 bucks a capsule 20 patients and you
can just see him
calculating right that means if you go
to kentucky fried chicken and you buy a
bucket of chicken throw away the skin
and the meat and eat the ends off the
bones
you're practicing medicine without a
license
and if you go to a kentucky fried
chicken in the middle of the night in
the dark of the night and you go to
their dumpster and you root through
there and you
collect two five gallon feed buckets
full of chicken bones
and you take them home with a hammer and
you pound off the ends of those bones
and dry your own cartilage in the
microwave you know
you're manufacturing pharmaceutical
and the fda is going to put you in jail
well if that's a little messy for you
you don't want to pay those lawyer fees
you can go into any
grocery store and get some knox gelatin
women know about knox gelling because
it's good for your fingernails and your
hair and your skin
it has the raw materials for chicken
cartilage
has the raw material for your cartilage
is made out of beef cartilage and beef
tendon and if you take
two of those little half ounce envelopes
a day in your orange juice and you take
it with an
ounce per hundred pounds of body weight
of colloidal minerals
next time i come by here in three months
you're gonna run up on this stage and
hug me and kiss me if you've got
arthritis
many of you ever heard of alzheimer's
disease everybody's heard about it today
50 years ago when i was a little kid
there's no such thing as alzheimer's
disease it's a new
disease one of those things that just
sort of happened now it's a major
disease one out of every two people who
reach age
70 get alzheimer's disease pretty scary
well
we learned 50 years ago in the animal
industry how to prevent and cure in the
early stages alzheimer's disease and
livestock
imagine how much a farmer would lose if
the pigs were all laying there
scratching their heads saying
why am i here
where is the feed box because if they're
not gaining a couple of pounds a day
you're losing money right so we learned
in the agricultural industry how to
prevent in the early stages cure
alzheimer's disease we do it with high
doses of vitamin e and low intakes of
vegetable oil
you say well like that's crazy high
doses of vitamin e well you should have
got a recall notice from your doctor
in july of 1992 because the university
of california
i mean we're talking about a
sophisticated research medical school
here
university of california san diego came
out and said vitamin e eases memory loss
and alzheimer's victims
now they're only 50 years behind on that
from veterinary medicine so it might be
safer going to a veterinarian
then how many of you in this room ever
had a kidney stone anybody in here ever
get that kidney stone okay i see a few
in here what's the first thing a doctor
told you to give up nutritionally
when you got your kidney stone give up
calcium no dairy
no dairy none of those vitamin mineral
things with calcium in them
because they have the stupid naive
ignorant belief
that's pretty intense they have the
stupid ignorant naive belief that the
calcium in your kidney stone
comes from the calcium you eat when in
fact it comes from your own bones when
you have a raging calcium deficiency a
raging osteoporosis
then you get kidney stones we learned a
thousand years ago in writing in the
agricultural industry if you wanted to
prevent kidney stones and livestock you
better give them more calcium
you better give them more magnesium and
more boron
the reason is of course bulls and rams
male cattle and sheep have special
anatomy when they get a kidney stone
they die they call water belly
they die when you and i get a kidney
stone we just wish we were dead
but no farmer is dumb enough to pay for
the feed for an animal and have it die
before you can either eat it or send it
to market
so we learned how to prevent those
things well you should have got a recall
notice from your doctor especially you
people who've had kidney stones your
urologist
should have sent a notice to you this
was
about 15 months ago march of 1993 it
says
calcium limits kidney stone risk and
this is from the habit medical school up
in boston by the way
in a study that turns conventional
medical wisdom on its head researchers
have found that people whose diets are
rich in calcium run a reduced risk of
developing kidney stones
in a study more than 45 000 people the
who were ranked into five categories the
group that had the most calcium
had no kidney stones so it took him a
thousand years to catch up
now about five years ago when i started
out on this crusade and started
lecturing to people all across america
and i'm in one time zone in the next and
all over i knew i was going to get crazy
out there
doing this last year i was on the road
300 days out of the year 300 out of 365
days and so i decided i needed to have a
hobby that i could take with me every
time i get a little wacko i could
go in my room and do this hobby and i'd
be okay you know be kinda like having a
little piece of home with me wherever i
went
i wanted to have a hobby that would help
other people i didn't want to collect
baseball cards because i like football
and i didn't want to do just crossword
puzzles because good mental exercise but
wouldn't help anybody else
and i couldn't take my compost pile i
like to garden and
hotels don't like that you know so i
decided i was going to collect
obituaries of doctors and lawyers
now as crazy as that sounds remember i
told you the doctors lived to an average
age of 58 and we live to 75.5
and here's a group of people
professionals who pontificate you and
tell you
well this is what you need to do you
need to give up salt and
no caffeine and you need to not eat
butter and eat margarine and do all
these crazy things
and they die at age 58 on the average
and of course all those people who live
to be 120 to 140
they put a chunk of rock salt in their
tea every day and they drink 40 cups of
tea a day
40 chunks of rock salt and they cook
with butter instead of
olive oil and they live to be 120.
so who are you going to believe the
people who live to be 58 or the people
who live to be 120 is your choice
anyway got a few of them here some of my
favorites this is dr stewart cartwright
age 38
he dropped dead in his home he was a
family practitioner
of a ruptured aneurysm that's a
ballooning of an artery that's a
weakened
artery because of the fragmenting or the
brittle condition of the elastic fibers
and arteries
just like when you hit a chuck hole with
your car tire and you break the cords in
there and you get a balloon
he dropped dead like he was polaxed okay
right in his home from a ruptured aortic
aneurysm
and we learned in 19 oh i think it was
57 aneurysms are caused by a copper
deficiency
we had a pilot project 250 000 turkeys
we made complete food pellets where you
put
all the 90 nutrients in there and the
first 13 weeks
fully half of those turkeys died 125 000
of them farmers were out there every
morning picking them up by the bushel
basket
they took them to the state diagnostic
labs in their autopsy they found out
that they all had died
from a ruptured aortic aneurysm so they
doubled the amount of copper in there
and the next year they tried to raise
500 000 turkeys and they didn't lose
a single turkey from a ruptured aortic
aneurysm and they ran
that experiment and mice and rats and
rabbits and dogs and cats and
calves and sheep and pigs and whatnot
and guess what they found out there's a
whole series of diseases that are caused
by a copper deficiency
gray hair is the first sign when you
start getting gray hair regardless of
your age you got a copper deficiency
you get skin wrinkles because the
elastic fibers in your skin are going
those little crow's feet around your
eyes and
facial and body skin wrinkles you look
like you're a little prune drying up
okay then of course there's the
varicose veins varicose veins
that's caused by an elastic fiber
breakdown then of course
parts of your body begin to sag under
your arms your breasts your bellies your
legs all this stuff starts sagging
and you can go to a cosmetic surgeon a
plastic surgeon if you want but
it's a lot cheaper and a lot more
effective and a lot safer if you just
take some
copper okay well dr cartwright may have
had a medical degree but he didn't have
expensive urine so he'd die to something
that even a turkey wouldn't die from
then here's one this fellow he was a
doctor's doctor dr martin carter he
almost made it he died at age
57 he got his medical degree from have
it medical school and his phd
in medicine from yale of course
he was autopsied by the best because he
was a doctor's doctor he said
quote the cause of death was a ruptured
aortic aneurysm said dr jules hirsch
the rockefeller university hospital
unquote what did he die from
copper deficiency see he didn't have
expensive urine either
then here's an attorney she was so
famous she was from detroit age 44
ellen joyce alter she was in the new
york times obituary she made the big
time
and of course she probably had steel
buns because she belonged to one of
those private health clubs
all these gals want steel buns you know
doing their little exercises
but she didn't have expensive urine
because she died of a ruptured cerebral
aneurysm
when they don't do an autopsy the
symptoms could be called a stroke or
subdural hemorrhage but very frequently
they're caused by a ruptured aneurysm
which is a copper deficiency she didn't
have expensive urine
how many of you here have ever heard of
a guy by the name of stuart berger
stuart berger he he wrote five
best-selling books on health and diets
and nutrition
uh he got his medical degree from tufts
medical school which is a very fine
medical school
in boston not too far away from harvard
and the books he wrote included the
southampton diet for weight loss
he wrote forever young 20 years younger
in 20 weeks and how to be your own
nutritionist
and he died at age 40. how'd you like to
follow his dietary practices
he died at age 40 of cardiomyopathy
which is a selenium deficiency
the same causes white muscle disease or
our
stiff lamb disease and any farmer can go
to a feed store and get
selenium pellets or selenium injections
things like celatoc and bosey
and so forth and dr stuart berger a guy
who wrote five
best-selling books on nutrition died of
a nutritional deficiency
he didn't have expensive urine
now you can prevent totally prevent
cardiomyopathy for 10 cents a day
and if we don't do it we're malignant
dumb i like to call it your malignant
dumb if you don't take in 10 cents a day
worth of selenium it's a waste of your
life that's one of those landmines you
can avoid
the medical treatment of choice for
cardiomyopathy as a heart transplant
cause 750 000 dollars
i want you to think about that they get
the heart free from a donor
they get the blood free for the surgery
from the relatives
they use two dollars and fifty cents
worth of suture material
and they charge a seven hundred and
fifty thousand dollars for that
procedure
now six months ago in l a when they had
the earthquake they were putting people
in jail for 60 and 90 days for price
gouging for selling these terrified
people
a gallon of water for four dollars they
put them in jail for price gouging for
selling them a gallon of water for four
bucks
now to me that's entrepreneurialism you
know that's being in business for
yourself if you had a
a way to distill water and make water
and you had a car and you could get in
there and sell those people a gallon of
water for four bucks hey more power to
you
because if you go to a 7-eleven and buy
a quart of evian water it's a dollar
twenty-nine
so four of those courts is a five bucks
[Music]
kind of interesting isn't it they said
it was price gouging because those
people were terrified
well talk about a person who needs a new
heart they're terrified
750 000 we should put those doctors in
jail
but we bow to them because oh that's
high-tech medicine
out of 270 million people in america you
save about 50 a year
is that cost-effective i don't think so
i don't think so
any rate dr stuart berger didn't have
expensive urine here's the last one and
many of you may know this woman
her name is dr gail clark she was age 47
she was the chief cardiologist of the
west st louis county
group of hospitals she was the chief
cardiologist for the um
st mary's health center in richmond
heights in st louis county she's age 47
guess what she died from heart attack a
cardiomyopathy heart attack
you can just see her walking down the
hall she's got the stethoscope around
her neck you know this is their
little status symbol got my stethoscope
around my neck back when i was in school
they folded it up very
bravely and put it in their pocket boom
she falls down she has a heart attack
right in the hall
and of course the nurses scoop her up
and put her on a gurney and they call
the technicians in another doctor code
three code three
code blue whatever it is and they whip
her into the room
and you can hear them let's say you're a
cardiac patient you're laying there
you're all hooked up to the monitors and
the ivs and
and you hear them say okay tear clothes
off
okay stand back didn't work turn it up
stand back
and then you hear that terrible sound
when you know that the
treatment didn't work
the flat line when you know the heart is
gone and everybody walks out of the room
dejected and you say
nurse nurse what happened next door and
she says well
your cardiologist you know the chief
cardiologist at this hospital age 47 dr
gail clark
just died of a cardiomyopathy heart
attack you can see all the patients are
holding their gowns
and they're running out of that hospital
leaving their watches and their shoes
and their
checkbooks and everything they're
plastic credit cards because they don't
want to get what dr
gail clark got to me the reader's digest
is a magazine that never says anything
negative or bad about anybody or any
group
it's the sweetest little magazine that
ever was the september 1993
issue features an article that says can
you trust your doctor
it lists 12 ways the doctors scam your
money now let you read 11 of them
yourself i'll give you the worst one
in addition to their income from office
fees and surgical fees and lab fees and
hospitalization
in addition to all those fees doctors
get a kickback from the labs and the
the x-ray labs and clinics and hospitals
they get a kickback of 421 dollars every
time
they send you in for a cat scan or an
mri
and doctors tell you oh we do that
because we're practicing defensive
medicine because if i miss something
you know one in 10 billion you're gonna
sue me so i do this
just to protect myself well if it was
just to protect themselves and you knew
them and they knew you
ninety percent of the people say oh just
skip it doc if you don't really think
it's necessary let's save the money
but they got something more than
defensive medicine to worry about
they get 421 bucks in a kickback for
every time they send you in
for an mri or a cat scan well when i
practice for 12 years up in portland
somebody come to me with a terrible
headache
never had one i'd just walk up to them
and tap them on the sinuses and if they
collapsed to their knees i know they had
a sinus headache oh doc why'd you do
that well i just wanted that's a cheap
lab test you know
then if they had thank you
if they had blood dripping out of their
nose
nose it'd take a 35 x-ray to see if they
had a cancer in there
35 bucks and a free lab test as opposed
to 421 bucks
if i wanted to make that 421 bucks i'd
have been a good thief
what i'd have done i had to build a
shoot right into that cat scan machine
because i knew how to build shoots
living on a farm and i'd have gone out
in the street and i'd got every homeless
person i'd line them up in them shoots
and i'd put soup and a big mac at the
end of that tube you know
and i say i'm going to get buy you a
dollar fifty dinner i'm a good guy i'm
gonna buy you a dollar fifty dinner you
just gotta go through this shoot go
through that tube and you get your
sandwich and your soup man they'd be
flowing through there maybe a hundred a
day
and i could start adding some things up
it'd be a lot of fun
anyway the average doctor gets 228
660 dollars a year in cat scan kickbacks
a quarter of a million dollars a year
and any other industry if
you do that politicians
lawyers businessmen
stock brokers they get put in jail
but doctors it's okay
because insurance pays for it hillary
will pay for it we don't mind if they
steal his blind
it's free well i remember i told you i
was going to tell you about pica
pika is a funny disease p-i-c-a i'm not
talking about the type style
that you see in typewriters and
computers but pika is a disease that
farmers know about
in horses it's called cribbing when they
chew on the feed bunk the wooden feed
bunk
you know you better give them some
minerals otherwise they're going to eat
that feed bunk
also uh in cattle dairy cattle
especially they're losing lots of
minerals through their milk
all the time intense of milking you'll
see them picking up big rocks in the
creek and chewing on them or they'll
chew on barbed wire or maybe you'll see
them walking
down through a path with a deer bone in
their mouth or something or a shingle
that's called pica and a good farmer
husband dreamer knows you better give
them some minerals otherwise they're
going to eat the barn or something
in human beings we see this at funny
times pregnant women are notorious for
pica
uh in the middle of the night they'll
elbow their husband and say hey you
better get up i want some
pickles and ice cream they're craving
minerals because that fetus is pulling
minerals out of their body
they need some more minerals and so it's
it's recognized as a craving for things
like
sweets and salt and so forth we see this
in pregnant women i used to have people
come to my practice and they say doctor
i need to go see a shrink i said why is
that
well i wake up in the middle of the
night and i go outside with a spoon and
i eat dirt
and no that's okay just make sure it's
clean dirt
then they say my kid sits there with a
kitty litter box between his legs and
he has a spoon and he's eating that
stuff out of the kitty litter box
and then in housing projects little kids
will eat lead paint
off the walls and they get lead poison
get learning disabilities and bone
problems and anemia
we're good so we spend five million
dollars to scrape the lead paint off of
there and repaint it with latex paint
and all we have to do is give those kids
10 cents a day worth of minerals be
better for them and save us 5 million
bucks
it's your tax money and if we allow them
to throw them away
those dollars is kind of interesting any
rate
if you have a selenium deficiency and
you don't want to wait until you
get cardiomyopathy and drop dead from a
heart attack to recognize it
if you look on your hands and look in
the mirror in your face if you have
liver spots or age spots and i see
quite a few from here you have an early
selenium deficiency that's called free
radical damage
and fortunately for you if you recognize
that and you start taking in some
colloidal selenium in four to six months
those will all go away
you'll reverse that in four to six
months and when they go away on the
outside they're going away on the inside
and your brain and your heart and your
liver
and your kidneys and if you have low
blood sugar how many in this room
have low blood sugar anybody in here
have low blood sugar okay about ten
percent
how many of you ever seen a hyper active
kid who gets on sugar
okay about everybody in the room people
who have sugar problems
are like alcoholics there's good ones
and bad ones
you know the good alcoholics are one
when they get two drinks they just go
off in a corner and go to sleep right
same way with somebody with low blood
sugar they eat a big meal or they eat a
piece of pie three hours later
they clunk out and go to sleep then
there's bad alcoholics they're the one
that gets two drinks in them and they
get violent and raged and they want to
fight everybody
they punch holes in the wall you know
big brave fellows and they kicked their
wife and kicked the dog and take the
chainsaw and cut their neighbor's tree
down and
all these wild things and drive reckless
down the roads and kill people
those are the bad drunks well people who
have blood sugar problems there's bad
blood sugar people too
be a little crazy okay i don't know how
many of you remember the twinkie defense
right remember somebody murdered two
people and he claimed he ate a twinkie
three hours before he murdered him so
they let him off because he got
temporarily insane every time he ate
sugar
now don't any of you try that
well chromium and vanadium deficiency
will result
in these sugar problems low blood sugar
and if you let it go on for any length
of time you develop diabetes
chromium and vanadium in a tin
deficiency the early symptoms of a tin
deficiency
are male pattern baldness i see a lot of
tin deficiency in this room
yes and if you let it go on for any
length of time
you get deafness then there's a boron
deficiency and you gals should know
about boron
because it helps you keep the calcium
you take in in your bones so you don't
get osteoporosis
boron also it helps you make estrogen
it helps you fellas make testosterone if
you don't take in
enough boron you ladies are going to
suffer miserably
going through menopause okay you're
going to have all those terrible
symptoms
you fellas don't get enough boron can't
make testosterone you won't know whether
to lead or follow on the dance floor
you're going to be confused
she's saying he's got a boron deficiency
then in laboratory oh i should tell you
too we said this on the show today those
of you may not have heard it some of you
didn't hear the whole show
the first symptoms of a zinc deficiency
is you lose your sense of smell and your
taste
say oh you know food just doesn't taste
good anymore and you don't have a cold
or anything like that you say
your wife says well aren't you excited
about dinner i spent the whole day in
the kitchen cooking dinner i said well i
didn't smell anything when i walked in
you know he's got a zinc deficiency
on laboratory animals there's some seven
rare earths these rare earths are trace
minerals you need in
lesser amounts than you need trace
minerals and they actually double the
lifespan
of laboratory animals they've not been
proven in humans yet
but i'm not going to wait 500 years for
doctors to approve it they're still
arguing over vitamin c
and calcium right so i'm just going to
do it didn't kill any laboratory animals
just doubles their life and it's not a
drug
these rare earths are called lanthanum
prasiodimium neodymium sumerium
europium yider beam and thulium there
must be a reason why they're
named after old testament cities well
remember i told you we needed 90
nutrients
we need 60 minerals we need 16 vitamins
12 essential amino acids and three
essential fatty acids
of course we're lucky in that plants as
a group can make most vitamins amino
acids and fatty acids
plants can do that because they just
take carbon out of the air and make
carbon chains to make vitamins amino
acids and fatty acids
but you have to eat 15 to 25 different
plants a day in the right combinations
to make this happen theoretically it's
possible that most americans don't do it
the average american thinks if they eat
some potato buds out of a betty crocker
box or eating a vegetable
okay so you got to be careful what
you're considering a vegetable
then of course people want to do right
by their doctor and they eat low-fat
turkey breasts and they put a half a jar
of mayonnaise on there
and they put it between two slices of
wonder styrofoam bread
remember that stuff you can insulate
your house with and put your shoes when
you get a hole and shoe
i remember when i was a kid 50 years ago
it was a lot of fun because we have
wonder bread we didn't have tvs back
then on the farm we didn't even have
dryers that went round and round so the
only thing you could do in the
wintertime was
sit in the kitchen and wander to loaf of
wonder bread and
had the blue and red and green yellow
balloons on there
and if you read the labels many times as
i do you know it said things like
helps build bodies at 12 ways and about
15 years later the fda made them change
it to help build your body eight ways
now if you go to the store and look at
wonder bread
wrappers it just says wonder bread so it
kind of gives you a clue
so even though this is theoretically
possible it's not likely to happen that
you're going to get your vitamins amino
acids and fatty acids in proper
proportions
from your diet and so if your life is as
valuable to you
as mine is to me and my children's my
grandchildren's
is to me i would make sure that i take
in all my vitamins and amino acids and
fatty acids because i guarantee you
won't make it to 120 or 140 if you don't
you're just not going to do it now
minerals are another story we have a
tragic story when it comes to minerals
because
plants cannot make minerals in any way
shape or form and if they're not in the
soil anymore they're not in our plants
we have for you when you leave a free
copy of a summary of u.s senate document
264.
u.s senate document 264 is from the 74th
congress second session
and it says that our farm soils and our
rain soils are depleted of minerals and
the crops the grains the fruits and the
vegetables and the nuts that are grown
on these depleted farm
and rain soils are minerally deficient
the people who eat them
get mineral deficiency diseases and the
only way to prevent and cure them is
with mineral supplements as u.s senate
document 264 74th congress second
session
it was written and printed by the us
congress
in 1936 58 years ago
you think it's gotten any better no it
has not gotten any better it's only
gotten worse
and the reason is if you guys do what we
did and people continue to do
is we put npk on our land nitrogen
phosphorus potassium and you see it
as these three numbers and many
combinations of
ratios and these represent percentages
of these three nutrients nitrogen
phosphorus potassium
and those of you who don't have any
experience on farms the reason why we do
this is farmers get paid for tons and
bushels
there's no subsidy that encourages
people to put 60 minerals back in the
soil you get paid for tons and bushels
and for 40 bucks an
acre you can get the maximum yield in
tons and bushels
it only takes five to ten years to
deplete the land of minerals
because every time you harvest a crop
those plants pull minerals out of the
soil many
pounds per acre every time you haul a
crop out
so soon those minerals are gone and if
you only put back in three and you take
out 60
it's like a checking account if you only
put three bucks in your checking account
every month and write checks for 60
what's going to happen to your checks
boeing boing boing they
bounce exactly well i can tell you that
our health is bouncing right now to the
tune of 1.2
trillion dollars a year because there's
no more minerals left
in our soil it's our responsibility each
and every one of us to be responsible
for our health
and consciously take in these minerals i
have a lot of people ask me what did
these people do
thousands of years ago they didn't even
have commercial fertilizers what did
they do
these societies that had long-lived
people and whatnot i want you to think
about the egyptians the chinese
people from india that lived around
these great rivers the nile river the
ganges river
the yalu river in china and what used to
happen was every year or so would flood
just like it did here in northern
missouri
last year and every time it flooded
guess what would happen it would bring
silt or rock dust from mountains from
500 or thousand miles away
and those people would pray to every god
they had the water god the sky god the
wind god the rock god
to flood we pray don't flood they used
to pray to flood
because they had their floods during the
winter time and would put silt and
minerals back in the soil and their
grain was very valuable
king philip who is the father of uh
alexander the great married the 12 year
old child
queen of egypt cleopatra she didn't look
like elizabeth taylor all made up in
beautiful costumes
she was a little flat-chested teeny
bopper not very sexy
but phillip married her because she
controlled the best wheat in the world
and if he wanted his macedonian army to
conquer the world
through his son alexander the great he
needed the best wheat in the world so
you could march
20 hours a day fight for six hours and
win
if they used the wheat from the depleted
soils in greece they couldn't go
20 minutes without saying mommy pick me
up can you imagine these big greek
soldiers oh my legs hurt pick me up
and so they knew the best place to get
wheat was from
egypt it was those floods that gave them
those minerals and all those cultures
that came up with all the great art and
all the great technology came from those
p
places because they had more
intelligence because they had more
nutrition more minerals i heard somebody
say very good
we're getting the picture well what i'm
going to do here is i'm just going to
pick out a couple of minerals
just a couple of them so you get the
idea it applies to all of them
let's just pick out a common one like
calcium everybody knows about calcium
calcium
deficiency will result in something like
147 different diseases
they're just different names they're
named after people like bell's palsy
belle's palsy is you know everybody
knows about that one side of your face
sags it's not as true stroke it just
affects your facial muscles
it's caused by calcium deficiency we'll
talk about in a little bit
but everybody knows about this one
osteoporosis
it's the number 10 killer of adults in
the united states it's very expensive it
costs you thirty five thousand dollars
each for each hip to replace
it's okay it's free insurance or
medicare or hillary will pay for it
it costs you seventy thousand dollars
for both hips as expensive
as it is and number 10 killer remember
mrs skeets from radford virginia age 115
years of age she died of
complications of a fall we don't have
osteoporosis in animals and it's because
of farmers we don't have osteoporosis in
animals
goes like this you have a a pasture with
a hundred cows in it
and this year you didn't have any calves
you can't repay your operating loan
you're in trouble
right because you paid for the feed and
the vet bill and mowed the pasture and
fertilized and maintained the fence and
fed the cows and all this and the other
you don't have any calves you can't pay
back the opera
operating load and make any money so you
call the vet out and you say do i get
rid of these cows what happened here and
he examines the cows there's nothing
wrong with them
he says let me look at the bull he said
aha here's your problem that bull has
osteoporosis of
both hips can't breed the cows didn't
have any calves he said i'll tell you
what though
he says you give me seventy thousand
dollars he says i'll put two new hips in
that bowl next year you'll have some
calves well the first thing that farmer
says is stand back doc
boom he blows that bull away with a deer
rifle
and while the kids are grinding the kid
the kids are grinding the bull up
with a grinder and cutting roasts and
steaks off that bull the farmer's
chewing on a straw and saying now doc
pushes stetson up a little bit and he
says
you know he says you know i wasn't going
to pay you 70
000 for that old boy he said i get a new
bull every year for 70 years for that
he says but every once in a while i get
a bullet throws good calves i'd like to
keep him is there any way i can prevent
that osteoporosis thing for happening
to a good boy he says well yeah he says
if you'll give a bull calf 10 cents
worth of calcium
every day after he's weaned he'll never
get osteoporosis first
wait a minute doc you mean if i give
that bull 10 cents a day worth of
calcium
from the time he's weaned i can prevent
a 70 000
disaster oh yeah it's that simple he
says you mean all i have to do is give
up a half a cup
of coffee a day to do that he says yeah
that's it he says i choose that one
he says i'll give up the half a cup of
coffee and that's what we have to think
like
okay then there's receding gums
dentist and periodontists will tell you
that if you want to prevent and cure
receding gums you better floss and brush
after every meal
if you believe that works i have some
oceanfront property in montana to sell
you
if you all know your geography you know
that doesn't work
now as a veterinarian i've seen hundreds
of thousands of animals of all kinds
mice rats rabbits dogs cats sheep pigs
horses lions and tigers and bears and
they don't get receding gums
and they don't floss now they do get
funky breath but they don't get receding
gums
well if you want to smell something you
just let a camel
breathe on you boy
well the reason we don't have receding
gums and livestock is because
we've dealt with the osteoporosis
problem receding gums is not a
deficiency of flossing it's in fact
osteoporosis of the jaw bones and the
facial bones so if you have gingivitis
or receding gums
you have advanced osteoporosis those
bones around your teeth are melting away
a little bit by a little bit every day
and if you take your teeth out at night
and put them in a glass next to your bed
and that fizzy stuff
you have major advanced osteoporosis
because all your bone
has melted away okay then there's
arthritis
we talked about that a little bit
earlier remember the chicken cartilage
of the knox gelatin
85 of all arthritis is caused by
osteoporosis of the joint ends of the
bone you're talking about degenerative
arthritis osteoarthritis sciatica
lumbago rheumatism
all those sorts of things they're caused
by osteoporosis of the joint ends of the
bones i want you to think about
something for a minute
if you don't take a pain reliever or an
anti-inflammatory for that arthritis
let's say you get arthritis of the hips
you're going to kind of favor that a
little bit aren't you you're going to
get a cane or a walker or
crutches you're gonna favor it and so
you don't put any weight on it
i want you to think about that for just
a second because then i want you to
think about driving your tractor in a
field or you're driving a mercedes down
the highway either one doesn't matter
whichever you love more and um
let's say you didn't put the nut on that
oil pan real tight and all the oil
drained out
and that light on the dashboard comes on
says i'm getting hot you better give me
some oil
and that light irritates you so you stop
you open up the hood you get your
clippers out you know your fence
clippers and you
clip the the wire to that light you
close the hood and you just keep driving
would you do that to your tractor your
mercedes no you wouldn't
but we take those pain relievers for
arthritis and we go out there and square
dance
and do the texas two step and do our
five mile walks in our aerobics
that pill works real good doc because it
killed my pain
and you're just wearing that thing off
faster and faster
then your doctor is really going to get
rich because you need
joint replacement surgery then there's
hypertension this is one of my favorites
so i'll put a star over here
hypertension is high blood pressure
what's the first
nutritional thing that a doctor will
tell you to give up nutritionally when
you get high blood pressure give up
salt everybody knows that one has been
ingrained in our head
well they must think we're dumber than
cows because what's the first thing you
put out for your livestock is about that
big
a salt block no farmer is going to be
economically viable if you don't put a
salt block out for your livestock
they're going to die
kind of your veterinary bills are going
to go crazy but we're supposed to
believe that we don't need salt you can
get everything you need out of your
lettuce and your whole wheat bread and
stuff like that
well don't believe that one either if
you believe that i got some more
oceanfront property in montana for you
remember those long-lived people put a
big chunk of rock salt the size of a big
black concord grape and every cup of tea
and they drink about 40 cups of tea a
day because they live at high altitudes
where it's very dry
they have to keep hydrated and they put
butter
in their tea they put two pats of butter
and a chunk of rock salt
they don't put the pink stuff or the
blue stuff or skim milk
or what does he call it cremora
or whatever it is okay guys
guess what the doctors who live to be 58
tell you no salt no butter
the people who live to be 120 they put
in butter and salt
so you've got to make some choices well
they took 30 million dollars your tax
money
and two years ago after a 20-year study
they came out and said that they took
five thousand people with high blood
pressure they took them off their
medication
and put them on a reduced salt diet a
restricted salt diet
and they all died no big surprise but
somebody got a phd degree and everybody
was happy right
but when they looked at this results
they said that oh only
99.7 percent of people didn't get any
results
from that before they died 0.3 percent
did get some result drop their blood
pressure one point before they died by
restricting their salt
so the referees who judged that article
said oh doesn't matter you might as well
let high blood pressure patients
eat salted peanuts and dill pickles and
salt their food to taste because it
doesn't matter
in fact worrying about the salt is more
stress than taking the salt
then they had a control group with five
thousand people with high blood pressure
and they doubled their rda of calcium
and they stopped the experiment in six
weeks because 85 percent of them were
cured of their high blood pressure just
by doubling their calcium intake
now they didn't cold turkey stop their
high blood pressure medication
but what they did was they went to the
doctor and says you don't need this
medication anymore
what are you doing well i'm on this
experiment where i double my calcium
intake
anybody get a recall notice from your
doctor saying it's okay to salt your
food to taste and
please do double your calcium intake
anybody get that
not a single one that's very interesting
then of course
there's insomnia that's where you roll
around all night and you get your
you wake up in the morning you're more
tired when you went to bed that's
insomnia of course doctors have two
treatments for that they have
halcyon which is a sleeping pill and
they have barbiturates
they kill about ten thousand people a
year with overdoses of those things but
that's okay
it's a prescription and they're watching
out for us and remember
remember uh george bush when he went to
japan they gave him some helsion so he
could sleep on the way to japan because
of the
time difference and when he woke up one
of the the side effects of halcyon is
nausea and vomiting
i don't know how you say it in japanese
but it was very dramatic on world tv
right not very presidential
and so i'm sure that's why he lost the
election because he puked over that
japanese ambassador
and then of course there's kidney stones
and then there's a bone spurs heel spurs
and calcium deposits again physicians
will tell you
the first thing to give up nutritionally
is calcium and dairy because they have
this foolish belief
the stupid belief the ignorant belief
that the calcium
in kidney stones bone spurs heal spurs
and calcium deposits come from
your diet when instead it only comes
from your bones when you have a raging
osteoporosis
and when you get these things you need
more calcium not less
then there's cramps and twitches you
wake up in the middle of the night your
foot is all cramped up around your neck
you say lord take me from the knee down
i'm not going to make it till morning
we've all experienced that that's very
common
then there's pms premenstrual syndrome
you know the emotional and physical
stuff the medical treatment of choice
for pms
is what we call a hysterical ectomy it's
been shortened to hysterectomy
that's a hundred year old treatment that
doctors do about 285
000 unnecessary hystericalectomies a
year but it makes mercedes payments so
they do them
even the ama said they're unnecessary
but they don't take their licenses away
and people keep going to them you
imagine a poor woman in her 30s
she says doc you got to do something
every time i go out to hang up the
clothes
my neighbor's kids run down the basement
screaming which my own kids think i'm
crazy my husband's leaving me i'm going
to lose my job you got to do something
well the university of california san
diego came out three years ago now and
said if you just double the rda of
calcium intake
you get rid of 85 percent of the
emotional and physical symptoms of pms
and when that came out there were huge
lines around the health food stores
around the blocks and people had sleep
in bags
because they closed before they all got
their calcium and every person in line
was a man
they were there for their daughters and
their girlfriends and their wives and
things like that
okay and lastly is low back pain
85 percent of americans get low back
pain whether you work on a computer or
you unload
hay or you drive big trucks doesn't
matter low back is a big problem
low back is just osteoporosis or the
vertebrae whether you have a disc
problem or whatnot
because if your disc doesn't have
anything to hold on to
your vertebrae melted away what's going
to happen to the disc
especially if you have a copper
deficiency because they're made out of
elastic fibers
they go like a water balloon with a lot
of pressure on them
well i just want you to look at this
quickly before we do the last mineral
low back you go to an orthopedic surgeon
or rheumatologist you might get a
muscle relaxant you might get valium and
a muscle relaxant you get a
laminectomy you get your vertebrae fuse
you might get a disc operation they
don't tell you 75 percent of time you'll
never be the same again
right pms you go to your ob gyn
you can go to an internist you can go to
a family counselor a shrink or divorce
attorney
cramps and twitches you go to a
neurologist you go to a sports medicine
doctor an internist
bone spurs heel spurs calcium deposits
you go to a rheumatologist
an orthopedic surgeon or a podiatrist
kidney stones you go to a urologist an
internist or a surgeon insomnia you go
to schranker
a sleep clinic or an internist
hypertension you go to a cardiologist an
internist
or a surgeon arthritis a rheumatologist
a orthopedic surgeon an internist
receding gums you go to a dentist or
periodontist
osteoporosis you go to all those health
specialists including a tum salesman
for nothing more than a calcium
deficiency it costs you 10 cents a day
to deal with
now on the average because americans
have insurance and we have medicare and
medicaid
we spend on the average twenty five
thousand dollars to two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars
and we undergo five to ten surgical
procedures a year
for a calcium deficiency and we beg the
doctors to do it
we beg the doctors to do it well it's
our choice
the last one i'll share with you is
diabetes
everybody's touched by diabetes it's the
number three cause of death in adults in
the united states
number three cause of death and it has
terrible complications and side effects
diabetes
the side effects include blindness of
many kinds
then there's a kidney failure with
dialysis and kidney transplant there's
cardiovascular
disease of all kinds and of course that
contributes the number one cause of
death
which is the number one cause of death
uh then there's amputations everybody
ought to have one of those because
they're totally paid for
in their health thing because they
assume that you're not just going to get
one because you want to get everything
on your health benefits
and then you shorten your life because
if you have diabetes on the average
you have a shorter life span than
someone who doesn't have diabetes now
we learned in 1957 in the animal
industry that we could prevent and cure
diabetes with two trace minerals that's
a pretty profound statement that we
could prevent and cure diabetes with two
trace minerals in 1957 and animals
it was published in federation
proceedings which is the official
journal of the
american science the national institutes
of health
the official monthly journal was august
well the two trace minerals that you can
get to prevent and cure this
are chromium and vanadium vanadium alone
according to the university of vancouver
british columbia medical school
vanadium alone will replace insulin
in adult onset diabetics which represent
of all diabetics of course they can't
quit their insulin cold turkey they got
to gradually wean off of it
takes four to six months for most people
to slowly wean off of insulin if they're
taking in
adequate amounts of chromium and
vanadium i've seen it work on hundreds
and hundreds of people now to me this is
criminal
because if you write to uh hill's
packing company that makes science dot
dog food right over here in topeka
kansas i don't know if i'm pointing west
but
that way okay they're all saying that
way
topeka kansas so they manufacture
science diet dog food and other science
diet product high tech foods for animals
if you write them and say how many
minerals exactly is in science diet for
dog food they'll write you back and say
there's 40 minerals
you're right checkerboard square in st
louis ralston korean say just how many
minerals
are in your wrap pellets for laboratory
rats and they'll say there's 28 minerals
i'll give anybody in this room a crisp
new hundred dollar bill if you can find
me a human infant formula in a grocery
store that has more than 11.
so our dogs get 40 minerals remember
that's what mike murphy was saying his
dog never seems to get sick
because he's getting this canned dog
food with all these vitamins and
minerals in there
so our dogs get 40 minerals our rats get
28 minerals and our human infants get
11.
is that fair no that's called
fraud doesn't matter if you're talking
about
sma similac isomil prosoybe
in fact that's why they call similac
similac because it lacks everything
okay if i've convinced you that you have
to consciously take in
all the minerals yourself that you can't
depend on your food
and certainly can't depend on anything
that's boxed or packaged or bottled
there's three types of minerals that you
have to be concerned about one is
metallic minerals
metallic minerals are essentially ground
up rocks metallic minerals are things
like oyster
shell eggshell dolomite limestone uh
calcium carbonate clays of various kinds
mount marulinite clay
seabed minerals they're tums
they're only eight to twelve percent
absorbable when you reach age thirty
five to forty it drops down to three to
five percent
and i have to tell you a story here some
of you heard this on the show today
i ran into a guy at a meeting like this
up at grand rapids michigan
and this fellow owns a port-a-potty
business you know that's that green or
blue colored outhouse
man if we'd only had one of those back
when i was a kid we had these ones with
splinters you know and the
in the wood any rate um he said i see
some
something that describes that in my
porta potty business i said what's that
he says well we take those things back
to the shop to clean them out with a
pressure hose
he says we put a quarter inch grid
underneath them because kids throw rocks
and sticks and toys in there
and if we don't put a grid there it
blocks up the sewer system it cost us
thousands of dollars to fix it
he says every time we clean one of those
out we find hundreds
of vitamin tablets i said well how do
you know their vitamin tablets he said
well it's really easy
he says right on the coating it says
theragram m one a day centrum
he says come here he takes me out in the
back of the shop and there's this little
mountain
of all these vitamin pills he got out of
his porta-potties
that's because you can't absorb metallic
minerals if you read the labels on those
multiples they say
your iron it comes in the form of iron
oxide
what is iron oxide rust
you might as well just go out to an old
railroad track and take your butter
knife and scrape some of that rust off
and lick it
and you're going to get your iron
supplement that's what they're giving
you
well i'll show you how bad it is if you
take something like calcium lactate
which is a common metallic mineral
let's say it's a calcium tablet calcium
lactate a thousand milligrams
if you take two of those you're not
getting two thousand milligrams of
calcium in fact i have people all the
time say
well i took lots of calcium doc i hear
you on the radio talking about calcium
and arthritis and
i took two thousand milligrams of
calcium a day didn't help my arthritis
in fact it got worse
and so what kind of calcium you're
taking they said calcium lactate well
there's your problem
because only 250 milligrams of that is
metallic calcium
so let's say you absorb 10 percent of
that then the other 750 milligrams is
lactose or milk sugar
[Music]
so 10 percent of 250 is 25 so if you
take two of those tablets you're not
getting 2 000
you're getting 50 milligrams so to get
what you need you need to take 90 of
those tablets a day you need to take 30
with each meal and you got 59 more
minerals to go
then there's those people who want to do
things naturally let's see if you can do
anything good with 10 pounds of spinach
and let's be fair let's see if we get a
thousand milligrams of magnesium
i pick magnesium because in green leafy
vegetables you have a lot of magnesium
because of the chlorophyll right it's
part of the chlorophyll molecule
and any pound of anything you got 454
grams
and 10 pounds of spinach you got 4 540
of which most of that 97 is water unless
you have one gram
of chlorophyll and that 10 pounds of
spinach there's 50 milligrams of
magnesium
you got to divide that into the thousand
you want you get a factor of 20 which
you multiply times the 10.
you have to eat 200 pounds of spinach
you got 58 more minerals to go
okay so you got to be a pretty big
person to accomplish all this
even as big as i am you can't get it
done so i preferred a supplement
rather than do those things then of
course during the 60s the agricultural
industry came up with
chelated minerals chelated minerals
because farmers aren't dumb enough to
pay for a dollar if something
goes into an animal's mouth and have 99
cents come out in the manure
so i have to really thank farmers for
being that clever
and chelated minerals are just metallic
minerals with an amino acid or protein
or enzyme wrapped around the
metal atom and increased the
absorbability to 40 percent
then the health food industry jumped on
that right away because it was a major
improvement in absorbability of minerals
the most efficient way to absorb
minerals is the colloidal farm
colloidal minerals are 98 absorbable
two and a half times more available than
chelated minerals and ten times more
available than metallic minerals
and they're very interesting they're
liquid they can only be liquid
can't be pills powders or capsules
they're very small
particle size are 7 000 times
smaller than a red blood cell and
they're negatively charged every
particle is negatively charged your
intestinal lining
is positively charged so you actually
have an electrical or magnetic gradient
that concentrates these minerals
around the lining of your intestine
these three things together give you the
98 percent absorbability
now plants have a very interesting part
to play in colloidal minerals
remember we said that plants cannot
create minerals they're not in the soil
plants can't make them
remember that u.s senate document 264
says they're not in the soil anymore
at any rate metallic minerals are taken
up by plants when they're in the soil
plants convert them
in their tissues to colloidal minerals
and this is how we store minerals in our
body this is how we use minerals in our
body
this is how we transport minerals from
the storage place to their site of use
in the colloidal farm well our plants
our crops don't have much in the way of
colloidal minerals in them because we
don't have any metallic minerals
in our soil is this important well yeah
these long-lived cultures who live to be
120-140
they have certain common denominators
they all live in high mountain villages
that are above 8 500 to 14
000 feet in elevation they all have less
than two inches of precipitation a year
they don't have any rain they don't have
any snow
they don't have any dew okay very very
dry
places and guess what they get all their
drinking water and all their irrigation
water for their crops
from what we call glacial milk glaciers
in every one of those communities grind
up the parent rock of those mountains
about four inches a year
there's more than 60 to 72 minerals in
each one of those places
the water that comes out from underneath
those glaciers is not clear like perrier
or evian water
or poland water or geyser water you take
a glass full of it up and hold it up it
looks like
jersey milk i mean it is either yellow
white or white blue
it looks like milk and is called in
kitty cocka see i got to say it again
and titicaca are tibet they all call it
glacial milk because it looks like milk
and not only have they consumed it
drunk it and got eight to twelve percent
until they were thirty five to forty
then
three to five percent absorption for
twenty five hundred to five thousand
years depending on the culture
more importantly they have irrigated
with it year after year crop after crop
generation after generation for twenty
five hundred to five thousand years
they have no diabetes they have no heart
disease no high blood pressure
no arthritis no osteoporosis no cancer
no cataracts no glaucoma they have
no birth defects they have no
jails full of drug addicts they have no
taxes they have no doctors
yet they live to be 120 140 without
disease are these colloidal minerals
important
you bet your life they're important and
every time you don't take them in every
day
you're chopping off a few hours or a few
days of your life
okay now most people are not going to go
to hanza or
tibet or titicaca
because we don't have kenmore kitchens
there or even saturn cars or tv
changers channel changers or electricity
they don't have
insulated houses they don't have central
heating or air conditioning
but what they do have is colloidal
minerals
this is dr wallach for the final message
information gives you the ability to
make decisions with confidence
i hope you've enjoyed my message by
giving your body the proper raw
materials every day
you'll be taking the necessary steps in
living healthier
and living longer make the decision to
take control of your personal health and
longevity program
today colloidal minerals are not like
antibiotics you don't get a prescription
which you use for 10 days
and then you're done your prescription
for colloidal minerals should only
expire
when your need for oxygen expires you
need to supplement your diet with the 90
essential nutrients each and every day
of your life
millions of people have heard my message
all across the world and have now
decided
to make the consumption of colloidal
minerals a daily ritual
just as there are many manufacturers of
aspirin there are now many manufacturers
of
vitamins and mineral supplements be sure
to get your liquid colloidal minerals
derived only from the very best organic
plant source deposits
colloidal minerals are the mineral
source our bodies were designed to use
not ground up rocks since you will most
likely be supplementing your diet
each and every day don't get caught
paying retail prices
my daddy always said why pay retail when
you can buy wholesale
one of my trusted colleagues will show
you how to purchase the highest quality
products wholesale
so you can save gob's money off the
retail price each year
[Music]
dr wallach is going to explain to you
tonight
not only about cardiac myopathy but many
other things
i pray that you listen closely and
carefully
because what you're going to hear may
save your life or the life of your loved
one
dr wallach in 1991 was nominated for the
nobel prize
he's had many many fabulous things in
his life
you